[Music]
hey we've teamed up with a company
called the dream world to bring our
anime merch store to the next level
check us out at anime out Broadcom for
exclusive designs including some
brand-new ones dots anime upper calm or
click the link in the description what
is up everybody its Anna Mak here for
anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the apparently imminent
ending of the seven deadly sins with the
latest villain defeated the most recent
chapter of the seven deadly sins story
has signaled that the sins are all going
their separate ways and that the story
really appears to be ending in this
video I will be taking a look at the
events of the latest chapter I will be
talking about all the unresolved plot
points that are still out there just
hanging in the wind and I will be
sharing my own thoughts on this apparent
ending and on the current state of the
story if you enjoyed the seven deadly
sins content right here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar or you're not new but you
just haven't subscribed yet please
consider subscribing and hitting that
bell to turn on all notifications feel
free to hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar finally this
video will of course contain seven of
these sins manga spoilers I am directly
addressing the very latest events in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned
the latest chapter starts off with the
sins back in the onus after to fight
against caf-pow Luke Arthur and Merlin
are not there and we can assume that
they are busy trying to rebuild Camelot
and create Arthur's ideal Kingdom Diann
and King bid farewell to Melly Otis
Elizabeth and the others as they prepare
to return to the fairy Kings forest in
order to rule it as the next king and
queen of a united fairy and giant
Kingdom this is a pretty interesting
development the fairy and giant clans
are going to be forming a united kingdom
together and King at the end will be
their king and queen but this makes
sense there aren't that many fairies
in the world and there are even fewer
Giants so joining forces to protect the
fairy Kings forest and live together in
peace makes a lot of sense especially
since Deanna and King are the perfect
example of how Giants and fairies can
come together and coexist in peace and
love King declares that he plans to hold
his Indians wedding soon and he invites
everyone to attend but meliodas warns
that when a fairy and giant says soon
that may not be as soon as we think with
their long lifespans that stretch for
hundreds of years
Giants and fairies have a different
sense of time than say humans Elaine and
bond declared that they plan to take it
easy for a while and just go traveling
all over Tanya sampling the best ale of
the land which is one of bonds favorite
hobbies meanwhile Coulter says that
after defeating the demon king and kath
their job as the seven deadly sins is
over so he plans to set out on a journey
on his own a journey to find himself
kind of like a hippie going on a
spiritual journey to India like back in
the 70s dee Ann warns go third that he
will get lonely if he travels all by
himself but Gotha responds that he
already has a destination in mind and he
will never be lonely because if he is
ever in trouble his friends the seven
deadly sins will always be there for him
Mele Otis agrees proclaiming that they
will always be friends and this brief
moment actually does a lot to bring
Gothas character arc to a satisfying
conclusion Golder started out as an
emotionless doll someone who did not
understand how human emotions worked and
someone who had no idea what love or
friendship or kindness were but
throughout the course of the story from
his relationship to the original goal
third to his romance with princess Nadya
to his relationship with the seven
deadly sins Golder has come a long way
and he has come to understand and also
feel human emotions including of course
love and friendship that is made clear
during this brief scene and as a fan of
Golder I definitely appreciate this
little conclusion to his immense
character development throughout the
story at this point the sins go their
separate ways
go thir goes on his little hippie
journey Elaine and bond go on their
drunken trip and King at the end goat
fairy kings forests meliodas Elizabeth
and Hawk remain in Leonys saw it as just
as it was back in the beginning of the
story when Elizabeth first met malleolus
and Hawk and the three of them were on a
mission to rescue the king from the holy
Knights Wow remember when the holy
Knights were considered a major threat
we've come a long way except of course
for Lord to eagle who was never just a
holy night that was only a brilliant
cover designed to conceal his true
fundamental role in the wider story Hawk
decides to fulfill his promise to his
deceased brother wild and erect a grave
for him back in purgatory Hawk says
goodbye to malleolus and Elizabeth and
he calls out to Merlin to help him find
purgatory
Merlin agrees to send him there but she
says that she can't guarantee his return
it makes sense that Merlin can send him
there since Hawk is himself a portal to
purgatory but perhaps Hawk will have to
figure out a way to get back on his own
he might need to find a way to finally
awaken his dormant portal powers which
will then allow him to move between
purgatory and Britannia at will
meanwhile meliodas Elizabeth go to see
King Bartra meliodas proclaims that now
that he doesn't have to go back to the
demon world he intends to marry
Elizabeth and succeed King Bartra as the
next king of Leona's however meliodas
does have one condition he wants to go
on a nice long honeymoon with Elizabeth
before he assumes all the many tedious
duties of a king Elizabeth says that
they want to go on a trip to visit all
of the many places that they had visited
together in the past 3,000 years of
their rocky romance and King Bartra
agrees although he doesn't want them to
take too long because he wants to live
to see the faces of his grandchildren
over in purgatory Hawk finds the
atmosphere pretty challenging to say the
least
first it's hot then it's cold then it's
hard to breathe Hawke almost gives up on
the whole endeavor but then he randomly
runs into none other than Wilde himself
it turns out that Hawks older brother
Wilde was not killed during the battle
against the demon king rather he was
only injured and as a result of that
injury he now only has a million more
years
to live I assume that Hawks unique
abilities to be a portal for purgatory
allowed him to enter purgatory right
around the area where his brother was
but that's just speculation since it
could also be just plot convenience
let's face it having Hawkes searching
for his brother through purgatory for
like 10 chapters would not have been
that much fun to read the two brothers
share a heartwarming reunion and Hawkes
says what we're all thinking that a
million years is plenty of time to live
I have to say that this whole wild being
a live thing really took me by surprise
if even wild is still alive and Viviane
is still alive and all these other
characters came back from the dead like
Elaine and Arthur then it feels kind of
cheap for Eskin or to be the only major
death which actually sticks maybe that
too will change in the coming chapters
and knowing the seven deadly sins that
would not surprise me but until s Canora
comes back to life I am definitely going
to be salty about Vivian Wilde and all
these other characters surviving
seemingly certain death when our boy Big
Daddy sunshine could not all in all this
definitely does feel like a real ending
at this point although if this really is
the end and I am definitely not fully
satisfied I know that a lot of people
thought that the story should have just
ended with the defeat of the demon king
but I would have been totally fine with
this new chaos arc if it had been
executed differently we needed to get
more of Merlin's backstory she was the
last sin whose backstory we still hadn't
explored and doing that with this chaos
arc would have been totally fine Kath
was also a decent villain for this arc
he had some pretty interesting
philosophical beliefs about chaos being
the only permanent thing in the world
and his final form design ended up being
pretty good I also genuinely liked the
unique nature of chaos power and I would
have liked to learn more about it but if
I had been writing this final arc I
definitely would not have made cath the
final villain of the story he always
felt like a lesser villain whose purpose
was to be a lead-up to a much more epic
threat so if it had been up to me I
would have explored Merlin's backstory
to a greater extent including her
connection to the original go thir and I
would have come up with a better reason
for why Merlin was
so desperate to revive the power of
chaos as part of Maryland's backstory I
would have put a greater focus on the
supreme deity perhaps Merlin was the
only one who knew that the supreme deity
was actually an even bigger threat than
the demon king and Merlin also knew that
the only way to defeat the supreme deity
was to use the power of chaos this would
then give us closure about the supreme
deity whose existence has been pretty
much ignored for these past few arcs and
it would have also set up a much more
epic and interesting final villain
beyond cath Paulo I think that setting
up an old grudge between the supreme
deity and Merlin making the supreme
deity even more dangerous than the demon
king and then making the power of chaos
the only way to defeat the supreme deity
would have been a much more epic way to
go about this final arc that would set
up a legendary final showdown between
the sins and yet another divine being it
would have forced Elizabeth to face her
cruel mother one more time face to face
and it would have given us closure above
this important divine being without
making us feel like her existence has
been completely ignored for like two
years that is the way that I personally
would have structured the chaos arc with
Kath being a side villain the supreme
deity being the final villain and the
power of chaos being the only thing that
can actually defeat the supreme deity if
that had been the case then all of
Merlin's plotting and sacrifice in order
to revive the king of chaos would have
made sense without Arthur's resurrection
they never would have been able to
defeat the final villain the supreme
deity and yes a story like that would
have required this final arc to be much
longer than it appears to be but to me
that would be a far better option than a
rushed and unsatisfactory ending that
being said this is just my individual
opinion feel free to let me know what
you guys think would you have done this
final arc differently would you have
taken it out altogether and just ended
it after the demon king or maybe you did
like everything the way it was feel free
to share your thoughts down below
finally after everything we've been
through I have to ask is this actually a
real ending or is this yet another troll
by naka bouzouki like the infamous
epilogue chapters from about a year ago
please give me your feedback down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more summon that Lee
sense content right here on the channel
whether the series ends or doesn't
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you could also hit me up
on Twitter and/or Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime out pro patrons for
supporting our work and making these
videos possible with all the constant
problems on YouTube patron support is
more important than ever thank you guys
so much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata alone Adam the world Steelers the
school bus
Tyson Corina acquired respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell dress fitted ala beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt ski on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Eve Argus Sean Darth Joe Stanton JCCC
waka Barrie Gucci and Jessica Caleb all
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us face cowboys
[Music]